fun
wildfires in Greece ignite an Ammunition
Depot an explosive illustration of the
damage caused by extreme heat
as wildfires rage in many parts of
Europe and the Mediterranean scientists
say this July is on course to being the
hottest ever recorded a global average
of 17 degrees Celsius globally and there
are warnings that a Tipping Point is
fast approaching
the Eater of global warming has ended
the area the era of global boiling has
arrived
the air is unbreathable the heat is
unbearable
and the level of fossil fuel profits and
climate in action is unacceptable
Americans are also sweltering under the
Summer sun
U.S President Joe Biden is calling
climate change an existential threat and
ordered emergency measures to keep
everyone safe
today I'm announcing additional steps to
help states and cities deal with the
consequences of extreme heat we should
be protecting workers from hazardous
conditions and we will
and those states where they do not I'm
going to be calling them out where they
refuse to protect these workers and
that's awful Heat
some scientists warned that temperatures
could get even hotter
they say action needs to be taken now to
cut emissions and slow global warming
it's like we are facing death and seeing
that climate change is not just an idea
of science it is real and it hurts and
you are facing not just a death but
baking in an oven this is this is very
critical period that has emerged
this summer dozens of people have been
killed and thousands made homeless
across the northern hemisphere
while the fires are likely to die down
as the summer runs its course the danger
remains that what we consider
catastrophic today may become part of
everyday life tomorrow
Vincent Monahan Al Jazeera